and that's the thing is like in 2022
women are bailed out of every single bad
decision that we make like every single
one we are bailed out
so um for example like they used to
require women to be virgins to get a
ring we make the decision to sleep
around and we still get ranks
right that's one bad decision or let's
say we get pregnant
um you can get bailed out of that bad
decision because you get an abortion
or you can keep it and you can still
give it up for adoption
or you can keep it and you can still get
remarried typically where like
historically that you would have been
done for you even if you weren't a
virgin like you would be done for
and so you have those like being bailed
out of those bad decisions on top of
that women owned two thirds of the
consumer debt
so
um and all of the government programs
are typically women on them and they're
men paying for them so it's men always
bailing out women for poor decisions
that's interesting i was actually
talking to my dad about this
well he kind of brought up because he
watched he watched the podcast and um
you know
one thing that he kind of mentioned was
actually as women we probably have a lot
more like we have
because we're because we're emotional as
beings right it's like the longer term
impact of
these things that can happen
and the consequences of it can have a
lot more of a long-term impact on women
than it can men because obviously women
are more emotional
what do you what do you mean a long-term
impact as in kind of live life with
you know stress anxiety depression or
you know
feeling you know carrying that neck
toxic
um behaviors in them or
i'm just
i just don't can i have a specific
example of how it would affect men and
women differently okay so let's say for
example
um
a woman
has a casual relationship and then maybe
falls pregnant and then
and then
decides to
you know maybe they develop an emotional
attachment with the the
person but then the man doesn't for
example
and then then she becomes pregnant and
then she has to choose between whether
she wants to
you know have a baby or not right so
that that would be like a that would be
an example so but they're long-term the
potentially because women are wired more
emotionally the longer-term impact of
making that decision and and actually
going through the consequences of that
of the consequences is more on the woman
not consequences more in wisdom but just
as i'm just saying like as in
the action and reaction like as in the
as a result of the act which happened so
so the act is you're talking about sex
like casual sex yeah someone's having
casual sex they fall in love and then
the woman has a more longer term
emotional impact as a result yeah so
let's say then the father decides that
they don't want to be a part of that
child's life the mother chooses i'm
gonna have this child
then she may need that additionals as
you like to call it bail out
um
then let's say opposed to men because
that woman's emotional
needs are different well the but the
thing is like women are 100 in control
of birth men have no power and no say
and they're on the hook for child
support for 18 years
if they do
if if she does have the kid yeah so how
you don't think it's emotionally
impacting someone when they when they're
taking up to in the u.s you can get up
to fifty percent of a man's income
can you imagine getting two thousand
dollars a month spending a thousand
dollars on your baby mama
you don't think that's i think that does
that can have
an impact on it's like soul-crushing
it can be and you know i'll be honest
like you know i was i dated someone who
had two two two had two children you
know and
i know that you know he went through a
really hard time just
trying to be a part of his children
children's lives
you know and that that kind of
that does that does exist
but and then obviously he was distressed
because of it but
i would say that
the i would say that it didn't really
emotionally i feel like the emotional
impact would have been a lot more on the
mother
than on the man
because we're instinctually more
emotional
so so then what did that if if a girl is
more emotional wouldn't she not want to
kill the kid
what did kayla and the kid come into it
because you said we were talking about
that's why they would need the extra
bailout right that's what you're saying
i was saying are you referring to
killian kid is like abortion
okay i'm thinking like you're saying
killing the kid
yeah yeah
just get mad one day anthony
um that is down to whether you believe
abortion is killing a child or not
and that is like subject to a whole
avatar well yeah i know but the whole
the whole point is like that like women
have
rights in that situation and men don't
you see what i'm saying
yeah i guess but then it's
the woman's body
it's the woman's body right but it's
it's
happening to them right the whole point
is it's his wallet right yeah so so in
this case like women are 100 in control
of birth they're not they're not 100 in
control of who gets pregnant but they're
much more in control than men are right
because we have 10 to 15 forms of birth
control yeah that we can use they have
one yeah
but then if you think it like
financially as well like men don't have
to pay if they don't
they they can go to jail
exactly they'll have the there's a
consequence to that but they still have
that choice they don't have to pay
childcare but then that's what you're
saying there's a consequence in it and
that's what i was saying earlier you
know women have women going no yeah
there's no consequence for women to
understand there's no that i just said
no like as you said you could you can
get an abortion if you want you know you
can decide you know to like adopt the
kid give it up for adoption you that
there's so many you can there's so many
pills and
and contraceptions that you can take to
avoid you know these consequences in it
out once the sperm leaves the man's body
that you know he's his life is basically
in your hand and people like to use this
this example of
um
consent to
sex is consent to having a child but
imagine if a man were to do the example
of oh this woman right now
at the start she consented to having sex
with me but i just carried on even
though she didn't want to people be like
this guy needs to get put in prison and
you'll get four years
so the whole notion of consent to sex
but the baby's come when has he
consented to that i think you consent to
a child as soon as you have sex
but it's like this dilute like you know
nothing but i think we have like where
contraception has given us this fruit
so you say as soon as you have sex you
consent to a child so that means you can
sent to ejaculation
so if you if i start sex with you now
you want me to stop because we you've
consented to conjunction ejaculation
there's nothing you can do to stop me
because you've consented because that's
the same logic
yeah i think you know at the end of the
day if two people are having unprotected
sex
then
you're not getting one so what i'm
saying is you're saying is once you
consent to sex you consent to
ejaculation into the other person yeah
we've agreed on that because that's what
causes for a baby to be made yeah yeah
you risked that yeah yeah so
if we've consented to that if you now
have sex with a man and you want to stop
he can now say to you babes you've
consented to ejaculation so you're going
to wait here and you're going to hold
every single inch until i finish because
that's what you consented to is that
what you're advocating for
hold every single inch of what
[Laughter]
so now he doesn't want to stop
it's the same thing no